challenging time for the real estate
market here in las vegas a lot of house
hunters but not a lot of houses yeah
part of those house hunters latinos
christian casarez took a look at the
opportunities available
right now for hispanics and how one
family was able to get their keys
that's right well challenging is the key
word here i'm told supply is very
limited
but it's not stopping many folks in the
latino community trying to transition
from renters to homeowners the effort
and the sacrifice that we did to
to make it happen alejandra caldera
can't stop smiling after achieving what
many latinos say
is the ultimate american dream owning a
home
i literally open up the windows after
years of renting this las vegas family
took a leap of faith
and focused on home stability so we had
zero savings so we knew like
we were broke we can't buy a home
another major hurdle was her husband's
legal status
it was harder so our income as married
would not count with his itin
because it was just me because you have
to have the social according to a
realtor alex vasquez it's a concern that
hold many latinos back from buying a
home
without realizing that there are options
like the nevada housing program there's
down payment assistance programs of
course to help but other than that
there's
programs that you can get into with as
little as three percent down
it's no secret the number of latinos are
growing with an estimate of 60 million
in the u.s according to the census
bureau
about 40 of hispanic home buyers are
under 34
years old vasquez says the housing
market is very attractive to buyers
right now
because of low interest rates we
definitely recommend buying now
christian and only because interest
rates are at historic lows
which make a mortgage uh opportunity
or payments rather affordable he says
the first step to buying a home is
getting in touch with a professional
realtor
an easy step for this family i've always
had this picture of what i wanted in a
home i want people to have horses
i want to be able to have animals more
than 40 percent of latinos tend to
purchase fixer-upper homes according to
the national association of hispanic
real estate professionals
that was the case for the caldera family
that closed in august
on 280 thousand dollar home in north las
vegas
it's not just the look it's like the
lifestyle my husband's a charo
so he's like all about that country
living three months later the home was
remodeled and even made some space for
their horse spirit
several goats chickens and other pets
when it's yours you're like oh man this
is mine
and it's but it's a great feeling well
the biggest lesson the caldera family
learned in this process was to do your
research
and of course ask plenty of questions